MIDDLETON, TATUM, FRED VANVLEET.
>> MAN THEY SMALL.
>> THERE WERE A LOT OF GUYS
CERTAINLY WORTHY OF
CONSIDERATION IN THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE.
>> YEAH.
I THINK THE EAST WAS TOUGH.
LAMELO BALL AND BRIDGES.
JARED ALLEN.
>> WHEN IS THE LAST TIME WE
THOUGHT THE HORNETS WERE GOING
TO BE LOCKS FOR THE PLAYOFFS.
THE SAME WAY DARIUS HAS DONE FOR
CLEVELAND AND THOSE GUYS HAVE
DONE FOR CHARLOTTE.
YOU CAN'T ARGUE WITH IT.
>> NO.
NO.
I AM JUST SAYING THOSE ARE YOUR
SEVEN RESERVES OUT OF THE FIELD
THAT HAS GOT A LOT OF WORTHY
CANDIDATES FOR ALL-STAR
CONSIDERATION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, DRE?
>> I THINK MILES AND LAMELO MAY
HAVE SPLIT VOTES.
I WAS LOOKING AT THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE STANDINGS THE OTHER
DAY.
I FEEL BOTH OF THEM HAD ALL-STAR
YEARS.
YOU LOOK UP AND THEY ARE SEVENTH
OR EIGHTH IN THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE.
THE RECORDS IN THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE ARE NOT THAT STRONG.
SO WHEN I SAW THAT I AM LIKE I
DON'T THINK THEY WILL GET BOTH
IN BUT THEY WILL GET ONE.
I AM ACTUALLY SHOCKED NEITHER
ONE OF THEM GOT IN AND PROBABLY
BECAUSE THEY SPLIT VOTES.
>> NUMBER SEVEN TEAM IN THE EAST
AT 28-24.
CHARLOTTE SHUT OUT OF ALL-STAR
CONSIDERATION THERE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHO WE
THOUGHT MIGHT BE SELECTED ON
THIS NIGHT BY THE COACHES.
TYLER HERRO.
>> TO ME HE IS THE GLARING
WEAKNESS.
>> WEAKNESS?
>> YEAH.
HE IS THE GUY THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ON THE LIST.
TYLER HERRO HAS BEEN GREAT ALL
YEAR.
NO DISRESPECT TO JIMMY BUTLER.
IF I HAD TO PICK ONE GUY OFF OF
THE HEAT IT WOULD BE TYLER
HERRO.
>> YOU DID.
>> I AM JUST SAYING.
WE SAYING WHO GOT LEFT OUT.
BRIDGES, HE GOT AN ARGUMENT.
>> I THINK THE BUTLER, THE ONLY
THING THAT MADE ME MOVE AWAY.
NOT BECAUSE HE IS NOT AN
ALL-STAR I THOUGHT THE GAMES
MISSED.
YOU MISSED THAT MANY GAMES.
IF I HAVE TO CHOOSE ONE I WOULD
POSSIBLY GO WITH HERRO.
BUT JIMMY BUTLER, IF YOU PUT THE
BODY OF WORK --
>> TYLER HERRO, THE SIXTH MAN OF
THE YEAR EASILY.
>> MADE TEN STARTS IN THE 43
GAMES.
>> I KNOW WE ARE PLAYING
POSITIONLESS BASKETBALL.
YOU ANNOUNCE THE TEAM CHUCK SAID
SOMETHING IMPORTANT, SMALL.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE ONE BIG GUY
IN THERE, SABONIS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIM GET IN.
THEY ARE SMALL, CHUCK.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS ALL JUST -- I AGREE WITH
YOU, ERNIE.
IF I HAD PICK A BIG GUY IT WOULD
BE JARED ALLEN.
HIM AND GARLAND TOGETHER.
YOU FACTOR IN MOBLEY.
JARED ALLEN TO ME HAS BEEN THE
GUY IN CLEVELAND.
>> 16 AND 11.
>> YEAH.
>> I ACTUALLY LIKE THAT
ORGANIZATION.
I GREW UP IN THE MIDWEST
WATCHING JERMAINE O'NEAL AND
THOSE GUYS BUT THEY STINK THIS
YEAR.
I DIDN'T THINK SABONIS HAD A
CHANCE AT ALL.
>> 19-34, NUMBER 13 IN THE EAST.
I THINK THAT IS KIND OF A
DEJOUNTE MURRAY SITUAT